okay I thought the world here
I feel what I'm gonna find side by side
forever but at the end of the day you're
you and I mean and oh maybe they're
still good at new but let's be honest
our paths diverged a long time
yeah
it's probably for the best that we never
see each other again that's what you've
always wanted
mr. get help what
get up no I hate it it's great works
every time humiliating do you have a
better plan no we're doing it we are not
doing no idea
in this film we wanted to kind of strip
it back and wanted have more fun with it
you know I'm tyka had the exact same
idea and we were both saying things for
Ragnarok it's trying to have more
attitude
Ragnarok sort of a new cycle from the
light of the world and all the realms of
the universe it's the destruction of the
old' and the rebirth of the new that's
really exciting to me
surprise this will be such fun the way
that I've approached this is to rebuild
it in a new way look great dude
timely I think it's just perfect mix for
where the character and story needed to
go you know different costumes different
weapons different cast or characters to
work off give you a different energy
Thor has been a crisis he never went
back to Asgard to claim the throne he
wanted adventure when we pick him up
he's at the end of this search for
himself when he ought to be surviving
district I'd say the odds are about a
million fun you know I want to take
people on a ride and and inject some
comedy into it and adventure that keeps
people laughing along the way
it also has inspector call them the
stuff that gets people excited he's a
fighter
you